a few voters showed up at this polling
station in the capital Tunis mostly
elderly but determined to be part of
Tunisia second democratic election since
the revolution nine years ago despite a
campaign blitz by politicians and
pledges to improve living conditions not
everyone seems convinced many Tunisians
are angry with their leaders I very much
wanted to see young candidates
unfortunately it's the same old elite
security and economy should be the top
priority for the government my priority
is to dismantle the corrupt elite and
candidates manipulated by foreign
countries I voted for the party with a
clean record and a clear political
agenda two parties are competing for a
larger share of seats in the parliament
Rachid Ghannouchi who seeks to become
parliament speaker leads the
conservative another party its main
rival is the secular heart of tunisia
founded by media tycoon Nabil car.we
he's in jail facing corruption charges
leaving his wife Salwa smeii in charge
for mana Tunisians despite the political
instability the challenges ahead the
election can only consolidate the
Democratic gains of the past I've voted
for the party that will improve living
standards reform education and invest in
more healthcare Tunisians cash-strapped
government is desperate for loans the
International Monetary Fund negotiating
a new installment of 2.9 billion dollars
it extended three years ago is pushing
leaders to reduce inflation and
government debt